-Welcome, welcome to
"The Tonight Show."
You're here. You made it.
Thank you for watching at home.
We got a big show tonight.
Let's get to some news.
Well, guys, today New York
Attorney General Letitia James
announced a lawsuit against
former president Trump
and his three adult children
for allegedly committing
widespread business fraud.
[ Audience oohs ]
You can tell Trump's worried
because he just asked
Ron DeSantis to fly him
somewhere random
in the middle of the night.
[ Laughter ]
Trump is being accused of
exaggerating
the value of his properties.
The attorney general
cited a few examples.
One of them being that Trump
said Mar-a-Lago is worth
$739 million, but it was only
appraised at $75 million.
[ Laughter ]
Trump was like,
"Technically, with all
the classified documents,
it is worth $739 million."
[ Laughter and applause ]
You took it out.
Yep, $739 million, almost
10 times the actual value.
Trump was going to put down
$740 million,
but he didn't want to
arouse suspicion.
[ Laughter ]
In response to the alleged
fraud, the State of New York
is now suing Trump
for $250 million.
Trump was like, "$250 million?
That's how much my fish tank
is appraised for."
[ Laughter ]
"Alright. Just take the tank."
Yes, Trump exaggerated the size
of his wealth,
his apartment,
and his properties.
It's the first time he's ever
lied about how big something is.
[ Laughter ]
Other than his inauguration
crowd,
his vote total,
and his night with
Stormy Daniels.
[ Laughter and applause ]
"Take the fish tank.
Take the tank.
I hate to see it go."
Yep, the attorney general laid
out all the details of
Trump's alleged fraud, and then
she ended her press conference
by saying this.
-Claiming you have money
that you do not have
does not amount to
"The Art of the Deal."
It's the art of the steal.
-Ooh.
[ Audience oohs ]
[ Rimshot ]
That's a burn.
-Ooh.
-That's an accidentally locking
yourself in a tanning bed burn.
[ Laughter ]
"Help, help."
Some more big news from here
in New York.
This morning President Biden
addressed
the U.N. General assembly.
In his 30-minute speech,
Biden said we need peace
between Russia and Ukraine
in Europe
and also Rachel and Tino
on "The Bachelorette."
We need peace.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, Biden spent a good portion
of his speech on Russia.
You can tell he was serious
because he was doing
that weird whisper thing.
[ Whispering ]
"That's why we do everything
[Normal voice]
to defeat Russia!"
I like that whisper thing
he does.
[ Whispering ] "We've been
trying to raise money
the whole time.
[ Normal voice ]
Building more bridges!"
[ Laughter ]
Speaking of Russia, today
Vladimir Putin asked for 300,000
more troops in Ukraine,
and hinted that he hasn't ruled
out a nuclear response.
The only thing missing
from Putin's speech was
a cat for him
to pet the whole time.
[ Laughter ]
Even Kim Jong-un called.
He was like,
"Dude, you're scaring me.
What's up?"
[ Laughter ]
Let's switch gears.
Guys, I heard that YouTube's
"dislike" and "not interested"
buttons don't actually stop
the platform
from showing you
similar content.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, they're basically
the elevator door-close
buttons of the Internet.
[ Laughter ]
-He's coming, he's coming.
-Sorry.
I wish I could -- Ah!
Hi, how was your weekend?
[ Laughter ]
Some entertainment news.
Apparently "House of the Dragon"
is averaging 29 million viewers
per episode.
-Ooh!
-But now I think
all the networks are trying
to get in on the action.
I watched CNN this morning.
Wolf Blitzer looks
a little different.
Take a look.
Do you see what I'm saying?
[ Laughter ]
They're all trying to do it.
-It's crazy.
-Yeah.
Hey, guys, I read that American
Airlines just announced hackers
accessed
the personal information
of some of their customers.
But you can look at it this way.
When they use your credit card,
you still get miles.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh!
-And finally, speaking of
airlines, I saw that Southwest
surprised a full flight with
ukulele lessons
on a trip
from California to Hawaii.
Take a look at this.
[ Laughter ]
The person in front of
the emergency exit was like,
"This counts, right?"
[ Laughter ]
They didn't just clap
when that plane landed.
They gave him
a standing ovation.
[ Cheers and applause ]
We have a great show, everyone.